I think a lot of women
don't live life on easy mode because
they feel like they have something to
prove and I'm like I'm not like I'm 100
if if a rich old man that I found
physically attractive and therefore
would happily have sex with if they were
like Amy I'm gonna financially take care
of you you can not work you can do her
DMS are open 100 please 100 if if a rich
you don't even need to be rich you need
to just be if a man and this is
anti-feminist but if a man said to me
Amy I will take care of you you don't
have to work you just have to and
genuinely yeah if a man wait what do you
get what do you get what do you get
sexual favors on command
not on commands what do you mean he's
taking care of all your bills yeah but
sometimes the coochie is tight sometimes
it's like I'm tired like everybody's
taking care of 100 of the bills I'll
make it
worked
but then that makes it's working a lot
why would you let him sleep with other
women
um that would depend on if I was like
emotionally attached to him if like oh
that would like that he's only going to
take care of you and fund your entire
lifestyle that you want
if you accept him he's going to sleep
with other women yeah but then I'd sleep
with other men no no no no you can't see
what I mean because you're not paying
for his life but if I have a vibrator so
I'd be like you know what if I've got a
comfortable life and it's just sex like
if I really cared about him then that's
like different but if I was only with
him for the money in the comfort no you
can't you can't you care about him you
care about him you like who he is he
says I'm going to take care of you you
live the lifestyle you want but you have
to accept that he's going to sleep with
other people
I wouldn't like it but knowing me I've
stayed with cheaters I've stayed with
cheaters so I'd just be like you know
you're not cheating because he's not
lying
do you know what I think that would be
more on me that would be more on me if
he cheated and my self-esteem or my
Worth or XYZ if I went Amy do you want
commitment stability uh exclusivity or
do you want discomfort in his lifestyle
and if I went
I prioritize his comfort in this
lifestyle then I would have to be like
I'm asking you right now would you
prioritize that or would you prioritize
exclusivity
I don't know I don't I don't know I
didn't
would you choose
I already knows
you're taking that lifestyle baby I
don't know I'm kidding I wouldn't do
cheating actually you would you if you
could if you could give you the
lifestyle that you wanted you wouldn't
take it all right I'll go to my dad what
do I need him for
that's very true no no I mean I can't
but like like they always say like
women's have mating strategies yeah and
there's five mating strategies have I
talked to you about these no for women
yeah and I always forget the fifth so if
anyone in the chat knows the fifth I
forget these but it's like so when we
see a guy there's like five guys
basically that represent so one is the
guy at the foam Cannon party well I
don't know what that is this is just
they call they call a guy that's a man
of spirit term the guys the guy the chat
gets it okay
that's that's the guy that's like really
hot like really just like physically
attractive like he has the jeans we want
right so that's like the girls that have
like a one night stand with the guy
that's that's why they call them they
met him at the foam Cannon party
I'm just I don't know I don't know what
came over yeah that's that's guy number
one creating strategy jeans right yeah
next meeting strategy parental
investment yeah so we want to know this
is a guy we meet and we think he would
stick around if I we got if I got
pregnant like I think he would like
provide time yeah second thing is money
so I think he could be he has the
resource it's kind of like the alpha
beta thing yeah but like he has the
resources to like take care of the guy
fourth is Legacy now Legacy is like not
embarrassing the family and like having
like character be like work ethic like
that sort of thing yeah and that's like
when I was talking to my friend torsha
who taught me this the other day
um we should go subscribe to her Channel
um she she said that's what when I talk
about like what I look for like that's
what I look for is Legacy yeah because
like the the money isn't as big like I'd
rather have Legacy yeah yeah so like I
don't want a guy that's like
embarrassing because even if like you
don't get caught you know it's even
worse I think getting worse than getting
cheated on it's like everybody knew you
got cheated on yeah I'm telling you yeah
that is the worst that is the worst
feeling yeah
embarrassing so and I don't know what
the fifth one was if anyone knows in the
chat because I forget well do you know
the uh different mating strategies for
men
um I would guess so so low body count
because they want to make sure the kid
is theirs yep so and then I would guess
um like like someone that would be a
good mother of the kids was like
femininity maybe like being like kind
that sort of thing
um in shape because like the the hips
right they like wide hips that's how I
got you guys like ass because it's like
the birthing hips or something there's
like a byline I think it's uh no um and
like men haven't men when I say men in
the west men haven't always like button
in the Black Culture it always has been
but I think the only reason not us is a
thing now is because hip-hop is
mainstream well I think think it's like
like I don't even think it's ass in
itself but like like the hip yeah child
bearing hits yes
and then like the boobs is like I don't
know the kids suck
there's something with that too
um yeah I think that's all the ones I
could think of off the top of my house I
would agree I would agree
I think um I think the promiscuous is
honestly how quickly she sleeps with
them
promiscuous as in like if she sleeps in
quickly he's gonna see her as more
promiscuous than if she doesn't do you
do you think that
if she is a kid that changes
whether he sees it 100 yeah because you
can't you can't yeah I'll be honest
would you would you tell your female
clients if they have a kid to like kind
of throw that strategy out the door like
he he ain't going to see you it's
probably not I would I would say that
having a child to a man is compromising
for him yeah and I would explain that it
is naturally male because as the male it
is we are expected to sacrifice for the
woman and for the child and there is
nothing biologically and naturally worse
than a man sacrificing himself for
offspring that isn't his that's why in
The Lion Kingdom the first thing that
male does is he kills the Cubs boy if a
new male takes over the pride he kills
those cops because he's like if I'm
putting my life on the line for this
Pride please believe I'm doing it for my
genes not anyone else's so
um
I'll be honest I know a few of my
friends would be like honestly they'd
have sex with someone who had a kid but
they they probably wouldn't marry them
if they have other options they probably
wouldn't
but do you think like girls should still
hold out if they have a kid hold out
like Uncle sex
because how is he gonna view you as not
promiscuous if you have a child I would
say I would say yes because
here's the thing when a woman when I say
hold out not like hold out for three
months when a woman doesn't engage in
sex with a guy quickly that's part of
the vetting process for saying which is
he the kind of guy who's gonna stick
around for you is he the kind of guy and
if he's not that kind of guy
then he's not gonna he's not gonna stick
around if you don't you know what I mean
but if he is the kind of guy who could
stick around
then it's in your interest to not be
sexually quick with him because
that's the best way as opposed to being
sexually quicker than because then he'll
be like okay well probably not do you
know what I mean do you so it's
interesting because I always hear from
like in the red pill they tell guys if
she doesn't sleep with you within three
dates to like move on because she's not
genuinely attracted to you
I don't I don't I don't I don't agree
with that I think it's I have a rule set
I tell guys who are coach if she doesn't
kiss you within the first three dates
for sure move on
um but I would say the biggest thing is
having sexual progression
so if let's say she doesn't kiss you on
the first date but then as she kisses
you in the second date but let's say
it's not a full out kiss it's like a
peck on the lips or whatever fine let's
say the third date she kisses you with
some tongues there's a bit of hands
going somewhere there's sexual
progression that's good and in fact if I
was being honest if I was dating a girl
I'm gonna take that girl more seriously
than the girl who has sex with me on the
first date
whereas if it's a girl if you don't get
anything throughout the three dates
facts move on she's not into you she
doesn't have General desire if she
doesn't sleep with you no maybe she's
just a woman who's worthy of being a
wife Wendy okay what as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible